i know why you're happy today the
vaccine now as of april 1st a few days
later
from now is going to be available to
people over 50
so uh agents all over town are calling
their clients and saying don't do it
it's a trick to make you admit you're
over 50.
that's that's how we handle things but
but it's so funny you know you can get
the vaccine of any age if you're a
smoker an ex-smoker or
live in a crowded neighborhood have a
handicap and the thing is
you don't have to prove any of this
because we are always aiming to protect
the key sector of the la economy
liars
and uh but you know
you can just tell americans we just want
to get out of the house
we don't even have to have exactly the
old lives back
just don't make us watch no mad land
that's really what's on
now you see what's going down in florida
spring break there in miami oh the kids
are going nuts
they're out of control as they should be
kids
should be out of control they're
refusing to wear masks which in their
defense
how are you supposed to tell if your
potential hookup has herpes if they have
a mask
it's spring break people
can you blame them
if i'd been locked up with my parents
for a year i'd want to snort xanax and
twerk on a squad car too
all right of course normal in america
also means the [ __ ]
that makes this country shitty mass
shootings again
we didn't have this for a while now
we've had you know one last week one
this week a mass shooting a 21 year old
christian lunatic
the week before and now a muslim 21 year
old lunatic
in a related story today an atheist went
crazy and rearranged
his books
a related story i made that product
and you heard about that i love this
story the world is really shooting its
pants economically because it's a
[ __ ] ship
stuck in the suez canal really there's
one ship you're talking about a traffic
oh my god it's like the 405 times a
million
people are and i love this part of the
story cue and not i'm not making this up
q anon says the ship
probably has ties to hillary
and could be transporting children to
molest you know what
you guys think about sex with children a
lot i'm just saying
[Applause]
how did you get there from boat
but biden had a press conference
uh and it's interesting you know he
hasn't had one yet this has been a big
talking point on the right he won't ever
press comments he did
and of course they've talked themselves
up there on fox news
into the idea that biden is completely
senile
like he can't get through a sentence
without forgetting what country this is
or any minute he's going to pee his
pants like bradley cooper
and a star is born you know
and of course he was fine for an hour i
thought he hit the just just the right
note
forceful without asking anyone to step
outside
that's joe
and of course his big news is uh we now
are proposing he is proposing democrats
want to sell this a three trillion
dollar
uh infrastructure uh plan which is you
know infrastructure in the broadest
sense of the world it includes child
care energy efficiency and buildings 5g
rural broadband retraining of workers
lots of stuff roads bridges ports rail
lines
redoing the electrical grid vehicle
charging stations
it sounds very ambitious considering the
last guy couldn't build a wall
but maybe i'm being too hard
but no i mean you know what
are of course things about it i have
trouble with but you know it's good that
country's moving again
yeah you know which we we've out of this
retrograde and you can feel it all over
and
things are happening all over like for
example in virginia first southern state
now that is banning the death penalty
they already got a call from west
virginia asking if they can have the
chair
and uh new york state where i've spent
so much of my time
gonna legalize pot finally okay i mean
this is
mayor i mean governor cuomo says he will
sign the bill
as soon as he gets done searching his
assistant for a pen
you